There's a medical movement going viral
called medical gaslighting,
where women are made to feel less than
when they bring up certain health issues
and I think a lot of us can relate to this.
And today we are working with OLLY,
and joining me to talk about women's health topics
that should have no apologies about them is Dr. Taz.
Hi, Dr. Taz!
Hi, Drew!
Thank you for having me.
How are you?
Thank you for doing this.
First of all, I am an OLLY customer,
it's what I give to my kids.
I am a huge OLLY fan.
It really spoke to me and I would love to know
why do you think that women's health concerns
and issues and questions get shrugged off?
Well, Drew, this is an issue and gaslighting is real
and I think what's happening
is for a long time women's health issues
have been swept under the rug,
they've been told it's normal, it's in their head,
it's a part of the aging process,
and there are many reasons for that,
but I think as women we have to advocate for ourselves
and we really have to try to find answers,
even when we're being dismissed.
Do you think
that there is something that we can do about it?
Absolutely.
Well, awareness is everything, right?
You and I are talking about it today,
I think it's important.
But I would say to every woman out there,
first of all, get educated.
Really understand their issue, make a list of questions,
get second opinions, don't be shy to do that,
and don't accept no for an answer.
I think that's really important as well.
Like, go after the information that you need to get better.
There's one brand, OLLY,
that's really getting behind the movement.
OLLY's starting a movement of unapologetic confidence
really aiming to spark dialogue
around many of these health topics that women face,
including low libido, normal hormone shifts,
and even gas and bloating that are often associated
many times with food and period swings.
I am your key demo
and I'm really excited
because I see this supplement bottle right here,
Beat the Bloat.
Absolutely.
OLLY offers self-care solutions
that really help to normalize these topics
that women are facing today.
What do we do?
You know, there are answers.
So here's what you can do.
Start with your diet. Food is medicine.
Remember, really increasing the amount
of plant-based foods you're getting in,
getting the fiber in,
decreasing refined sugar and carbohydrates,
all of those are gonna help to really bring gas
and bloating down, using digestive enzymes.
So don't order nachos
tonight at midnight-
No, don't do that.
When I get home from a party?
No.
And I'm curious,
why is this sort of inflammation and gas and bloating,
why is it always so dismissed
and how can we kind of target the questions
to medical professionals?
As a woman,
you really wanna be your own best advocate.
You wanna really have a list together,
go after your questions,
make sure you get the answers for them,
and don't accept no for an answer.
So this conversation is vital for me,
I hope it reaches other people out there
and I really took from you,
my takeaway is do not accept no for an answer.
Absolutely.
Get multiple opinions, and really be your own advocate.
Yes.
And be really strong
about it.
Yes!
And have no shame.
I am a big OLLY fan
and I'm really glad that you are advocating for women
to advocate for themselves.
Thank you.
Thank you, Dr. Taz!
It's my passion!
You're welcome. (laughs)
(upbeat music)
♪ Oh, oh, oh, oh ♪